I would like to show you a number trick. So regular scientific calculator.
I'm not trying to conceal anything,
but I would like you Brady to tell me what to write.
I'm going to put some fives into the calculator. Maybe you call the trick,
the surprising fives. I don't know. Maybe that's what I call it.
And someone else could think of a better name,
but I'm going to put the digit five into this calculator as many times as you
want me to. So tell me how many times you'd like to put the number five six,
two five five, five, five, five, five,
whatever have told me what to run with that. I'm next two steps at the same,
whatever we do, the first step is to take the reciprocal of this number.
You can see why we're doing this on a calculator.
I know that you could do it given time,
but the reciprocal blacks to the minus one or one over the answer, uh,
gives us this number handedly known as one over five, five, five, five, five,
five, so far so good. And now we take the sign of that answer.
So she's going to be sign of the answer and we get this.
Result, which is where I want to check what you notice.
It's a pie. Is it what's pie? Like it's probably like,
Oh, times 10 to the minus eight.
It's probably like enough to cause a reaction in anybody who's seen pipe before,
I think. Okay, wait, let me try it. Once you gave me six, five,
I invite you to give me a different number.
Okay. Uh.
One, one, five as a five. Good.
I like this and it must petition in the making here. Brady,
you see something surprising. You test the extreme cases, really,
really sensible mathematical things.
So reciprocal one over five is otherwise known as one of the five or 0.2.
And I take the sign of that answer and it gives me the answer 3.4906 times 10 to
the minus.
Three. Not so pilot. I kind.
Of talked you into giving me more than one, five a delivery said,
give me as many as you want. So invite you to try this experiment again.
How many fives do you like to start? 13, 13,
five. See if I calculate all cope, one, two, three, four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine, 10, 11, 12, 13 fives. So, uh.
As a reciprocal is 1.8.
Times 10 of them, negative 30.
My counselor has given up trying to display it as a fraction.
This is a tiny number. Take the sign of that.
Yeah. PI like.
You know, your pie expansion. This is pretty pie, like,
except for the whole thing at the end, which you did spot pretty quickly.
That times 10 to the minus 15,
this time that's the trick is a classic example of what I'd like to call
unexpected pie pie turns up literally all over the place in mathematics,
particularly when you don't expect it.
Obviously when you're doing stuff to do circles, it turns up,
we haven't mentioned a circle so far. PI has turned up somewhere.
There are several clues that I've kind of concealed from you, but.
Um, in the rest of the video, I'd.
Like to explain why this happens, but it's worth leaving as a,
as a surprise if you want to go.
And if anyone watching the video wants to figure out what's going on now,
now's the time to do it before I give it all away.
The only clue I'm going to give is your calculator should be in degrees mode.
Otherwise you won't get as nice a result.
That's the clue.
I like this trick. It's not so much a trick. It is that it's surprise.
And I think you need three bits of maths to understand it.
It's a nice example of simple bits of mass coming together to give you a
surprise chapter one, radiant. Oh, look at that. It's like an audio book.
Brady D do you know what a Radian is?
It's like a unit for measuring angle isn't.
That we, and we're used to using degrees.
So if I drew a circle and chopped it up into three quarter circle,
that right angle would be 90 degrees,
which means there's 360 degrees all the way.
Round 360 is this arbitrary number that we sort of inherited.
We didn't have to use it. In fact, we still don't have to use degrees.
Almost everybody learns about degrees at school.
And it's a useful way of talking about how much you turn three 60 would they
think is to do with our year. We're 365 days is close to three 60.
So a sort of full cycle of a year is roundabout the three 60. So there's,
there's a connection in history there.
The Babylonians used counting in base sixties,
which has to do with 360 or 3006 hundreds.
And all of these things are sort of historical accidents.
And we still see this in our time measurements in hours and minutes,
three 60 is convenient. You can talk it up a little bit,
but there is a better way to measure angles.
Let me show you the definition of Radian. Now this circle has a certain radius.
And if you start deciding,
I want to measure angles around the circle in some non arbitrary ways you could
use 400 say, and actually they do. They,
the call that gradients 400 gradients all the way around.
If you go to your calculator,
there's a mode button that goes between degrees and radians and gradients.
There's a G in there as well. It's a gradients means 400 bits around a circle.
It's kind of like metric degrees,
like cause then a right angle is a hundred and we will kind of recognized,
right? Angles are important. And why, why 90 then in some ways,
gradients are very sensible. I think the French tried it for a while.
They liked metric rising lots of things, but it didn't really catch on.
And not a lot of people use it a lot.
I'm sure people will comment if they found good examples of it being used,
but even that's arbitrary. I mean my pick 401, I'll go for a hundred.
When I go for a thousand, we could do anything. And actually our choice is free.
We just have to accept the consequences.
So what you might want to do is pick a measure that has fewer horrible
consequences and more nice consequences and everything to do with the circle is
tied up with this radius. And you can already see a clue in the name,
radians that as long as I talk about,
so this circle has a radius of one complete turn seems important,
but another amount of a turn would be, if you start walking around the circle,
some distance, why don't we pick a distance? There's already part of the circle,
which is a radius. So if you know the radius,
what would happen if you walked around the circle, a radius is one radiant.
So the name is good. If you shorten it to rat, is, is one radius of a turn.
So it's making length and angle measured the same way on a unit circle.
It means if there's radius is one,
then you walk a distance worn around the circle. You've gone one radiant.
It doesn't have a consequence which some people find nasty,
but just deal with it. All right, is that all the way around the circle
is not a nice number anymore or other is a nice number,
but it's not a rational number because you know,
the formula for distance around the circle is two PI. If the radius is one,
the distance around is two PI,
which must mean then to do a full turn is two PI radians. Okay.
So that's chapter one. We're almost there.
The little summary is that if you accept that all the way around a circle is two
PI radians.
It was also known in olden days or in our previous less wise status,
360 degrees. I can now write this relationship down.
Two PI radians is the same as 360 degrees,
which means that we could say that PI ratings is 180 degrees, I guess,
sort of this arbitrary too. And this gives us the relationship,
the kind of the exchange rate, if you like.
So one Radian is the same as 180 over PI degrees.
This relationship is important.
That's chapter one of our little story we've got to understand the radians are
an alternative way to measure circles and they work like this chapter two,
the then small angle.
If I show you a picture of a graph, his set of axes,
and here is what it looks like a straight line graph.
This is a relationship between two variables. That is a linear thing.
They call it linear because of straight lines.
But if I show you that same graph on a bigger scale,
you could realize that I could have drawn a graph like this.
So the thing I'm trying to point out is that a sine wave,
which is involved in our calculation is a graph as a function has an input and
output. But if you zoom in on this sign wave right about here,
can you see that? It looks a bit line. So what we're saying is that,
although this is not a straight line function, part of it looks like it is.
So if I zoom in, in fact,
if you work in a certain angle measurement to patrol label in a moment,
then this straight line function,
which is only true at the beginning is actually the graph of wake was X.
Whereas the original function is Y equals signings.
And I hope you recognize now that the title is kind of relevant when angles Mo
sine X and X are basically the same thing. Here's my conclusion.
You can go and look up some ways to prove it.
But visually it's pretty convincing if you zoom in on the sign graph,
sign X is approximately X, two caveats,
the small angles, and only in radians,
which is important that we had chapter one available to us.
If you drew a graph of this in degrees,
which then this straight line does not have a gradient of one,
which the claiming is, if you, if you think about this line being,
going up to one here and you drop a line down here, it's about 60 degrees there.
So the gradient of that line in degree, yeah.
Is this like one over 60 tiny number?
So the question is what cool measurement do you need to make?
You have a gradient of one, which is what I'm claiming. Yeah. We,
you need that to be one and then it would be great.
And one of then if you realize that that, that there's a two,
and then that's a three, my scale, Elizabeth rubbish,
but that means this must be pie and that's to buy.
And they were back to our readings idea.
So this fact sign X is approximately X cause more angles.
And if the measured ingredients end of chapter two, chapter three fractions,
you remember the, in the trick we did a reciprocal. In fact,
we did one over five, five, five, five, five, five.
And actually what's important is to recognize that as a decimal,
that looks different. And actually when you gave me six,
the calculators spat that fraction back is like one of the five, five, five,
five, and five is one of the five, five, five, five, five, five,
which is slightly annoying of the calculator telling you the question when you
just asked it what the answer is. So it has a decimal.
All we could do is do a bit of long division and work it out.
Or I could force the calculator to tell me it's a six fives. I do.
The reciprocal of that one over that.
[Inaudible] otherwise known as according to my calculator,
0.0000018.
Very faintly.
You can see there's a dot above the second zero dot above the eight.
Do you know what these dots mean? I've never seen them in Europe.
They wouldn't recognize them. Yeah.
In Europe, they might write this like this.
But that in Thai bar, but that also might make you look horrified.
Is that more familiar to recurring? Yes. Um, for some reason,
Britain has inherited the dot notation or you Mark the place where it starts
with caring with adult and place where it stops for, with the dot.
And then you just carry on. Most people use in the rest of the world.
I think use a line. They call it a [inaudible].
It's the same line name as the line between a numerator and
denominator. They say, there's a fine line between a numerator and denominator.
And it's called a [inaudible] anyway.
And this is one of the thing is it's a recurring decimal.
So if I didn't put the dots on here, if I wrote this character here,
(000) 018-0001 807. So turning fractions into decimals. Now what we could do,
if you were so inclined, and maybe I encourage any watches, the video,
you could go the other way around,
you could check this recurrent decimal and say, if that's a recurrent decimal,
how do you turn that back into a fraction?
It's actually because of school level of skill, but when it's this long,
a recurring thing, it takes a little bit of guts to go through the process.
But for now there's one thing in this decimal expansion,
which was not obvious in the fraction,
that gives us a clue about why this is working.
And it's the only numbers that are kind of significant in here is these two
numbers possibly followed by the zero after it.
And if I just refer back to a piece of paper from chapter one,
I'm trying to point out this number has turned up and suddenly we get glimpse of
why these things are coming together.
The conclusion of all three chapters is when we put these facts together and
we'll do the trick again with all three facts now, sort of under our control.
And hopefully it becomes obvious why the unexpected pipe.
Ends up. So let's try it.
First of all, you did one over five, five, five, five, five, five.
Do you accept the answer to that calculation is.
Yeah. Which means.
In this world of small angle,
approximately if I'm going to do a sign of something, I mean,
this world is small-angle approximations, but I didn't say at the very start,
but I did admit it at the end. I needed your calculator.
To be in degrees, not these magic.
Radiants we've been talking about. So if I do one over five, five, five, five,
five, five, and then take the sign of it,
which is what our whole calculation was.
It is not going to be equal to one over five, five, five, five, five, five,
or even approximately cause we weren't working yet.
In radians. If we were working in radians,
then the input will be the same as the app.
That was my small angle business. So let's go back to our three,
starting at the end, chapter three, the decimal version of your number.
I'm going to write it as 1.8 times 10 to the negative
something let's check, uh, one, two, three, four, five,
six, so 10 to the negative six,
but we're working in degrees.
So if I wanted to turn it into radians so that I could start using my small
angle approximation up here, I need to check back chapter one,
my conversion turn ratings into degrees. In fact,
if we wanted to go the other way round,
we better just check this just the opposite exchange rate.
I'm going to turn my degrees,
which is what the calculator was set up into radians.
So I'm going to just turn the into radius by multiplying by the exchange rate,
which is PI over one 80. So that was in degrees.
And this is now in radians. I've done the conversion,
which means I can now use this chapter to business to say,
this is approximately equal because sine X and X approximately equal because
this is small. There's no question.
This is a small number it's approximately equal.
Just to that number 1.8 times 10 to the negative six times PI of a one 80.
And you beginning to see the light at the end of the tunnel.
There's a pie in there.
We can see where it's coming from and there's some ones and A's possibly
canceling. So let's turn this into 180.
If I make that a hundred times bigger,
I better make this a hundred times smaller to compensate times PI
over one 80. And now I think you can see that one 80 divided by one.
It cancels out and I'm left with PI times 10 to the negative eight,
which is the end of our trick. That's where the surprising pie comes from.
You do a bunch of stuff to do with the number five and I'll pop some pie to a
very small power of 10.
And the reason you were using fives is because of the relationship between.
And this one eight. Yes.
Is it actually to do with the fact that there are five eighteens in 90?
So recurrent decimal is quite often to do with the number nine and ones were
recurring. It doesn't happen after every single digit ends up.
To do with being nineties and nine hundreds.
And so it's all to do with the fact that five times 18 is 90,
gives us a clue. It does mean that we should be to predict what happens though.
I had to do a scaling of a hundred to get the cancellation to happen 10 to the
negative two, our hundredth to make it work. Otherwise.
What you'll see is that it's to do with the number of fives over here,
we had six and that six is not a coincidence.
So we're probably in a position to make a prediction. We've done the process.
Once with your example, we should be able to do a general one.
Do you want to pick a number of fives that you haven't tried yet?
I mean 10 10 fives, one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, 10.
There are 10 fives before we actually do the calculation.
This is the power of mathematics.
We should be at an app predict what's going to happen.
We're expecting a pie to turn up, but what power of 10 direction?
If you turn this into a reciprocal,
I think you'll get a power of 10 to the negative 10,
but we're going to have to adjust it in our calculators like we did before by
another two. So I'm hoping PI times 10 to the negative 12
is find out, take the sign.
3.14159, blah, blah, blah, times 10 to the negative 12.
Even if it's a pointless trick, at least with the power of mathematics,
let us predict the outcome. There.
We are surprising pie from a surprising fives.
You know, when I graduated from high school,
I felt like I was on top of trigonometry. And now I'm not really sure.
I can tell you what a sign and a co-sign and a tan really are.
If you're anything like me and you want to brush up on what all this stuff
really means. Check out this amazing course on brilliant,
who are today's episode sponsor.
This is a fantastic way to brush up or get on top of,
or maybe even learn for the first time about what trigonometry really is,
how it works. What's it about? We'll look at that.
Some of it's coming back to me now,
this whole course has been lovingly designed by people who really know
trigonometry, but also really know how to teach it.
It's one of just many courses and quizzes and puzzles. You'll find on brilliant.
Go to brilliant.org/number file to check them out.
If you use the slash number file they'll know you came from here,
but also you'll get 20% of a brilliant premium subscription that gives you
access to everything on the site. All the good stuff.
That's brilliant.org/number file.
The numbers our podcast is available on. Well,
most podcast players just search for number file.
I also put it on the number file to channel. If you'd rather listen on YouTube,
the latest episode, the one that's just out is with Ben sparks.
So you've just watched, he talks about his life,
his career mathematics and what it's like having an identical twin brother,
check out the links on screen in the description, all the usual places.